[Music]
somewhere in these Dusty boxes and
tattered books are fragments of
information
and in them the fragments of Hope
that children who lost their lives won't
also be lost to history
communities need to know where their
children are
fundamental human right
Catherine Nichols grew up on the
outskirts of Brandon Manitoba three
kilometers west of the former
residential school
she took the school bus past it every
day we kind of Wonder with each other on
the school bus you know what was that
building what was its purpose
that Curiosity set Catherine on a quest
for answers
a lot of people don't know that in our
community of Brandon we had a
residential school
children died at that school and were
trying to find them
ready to look to sight yeah let's go
he's now a bio archaeologist pursuing a
PhD at Simon Fraser University
since 2012 long before the Kamloops
Discovery she's been working with Sioux
Valley Dakota Nation to uncover what
happened to the students who died at
Brandon residential school
we're standing where the Brandon
residential school building used to
stand
the large imposing structure stood at
the top of the hill until it was
demolished in 2000. how many graves have
you been able to find in total we have
about 104 potential on microwaves
[Music]
discoveries of unmarred graves across
the country have brought national
attention to the dark history of the
residential school system
but the findings have led to even more
questions
who were these children where did they
come from and what led to their deaths
with grave markers removed or lost over
time the anonymity of these deaths
continues to haunt survivors and
affected communities
researchers like Catherine are trying to
change that
I sort of set out two objectives could
we locate the cemeteries and were there
anyanmar Graves and could we find the
names of the children in the archives
she had hoped these boxes would contain
things like attendance lists death
records and Cemetery Maps
I think my expectations were a little
naive
uncovering the names of children who
died is a puzzle
one that Catherine has spent years
working to unravel
she sifts through documents like the
ones here at the United Church's
Winnipeg archives looking for any
mention of a child being injured ill or
dead
when we do come across instances of
children's names essentially what we
want to do is make a a case file for
that child and try and find out as much
information as we can
the federal government funded and
oversaw the creation of the residential
schools system but it didn't require the
religious orders that ran the schools to
report the deaths of children until the
1930s
Catherine compared those annual
statistics to the church's own records
to put names to numbers
but even then there would be
inconsistencies
the records are incomplete and often
lack critical information like what
happened after a child became sick
tuberculosis was very prominent in the
school and even more challenging if
they're sent away from the institution
to maybe a sanatorium or a hospital and
then what happens to the children there
essentially what you're doing is tracing
the children through the archives as
they go through the school exactly which
is why it's vital that we have access to
all the records to all the residential
schools and other Institutions and
hospitals so that we can identify where
the children are are going missing in
the system
Brandon residential school operated from
1895 to 1972 primarily under the
direction of the United Church
abuse and malnutrition were so bad that
in the 1940s and 50s the school gained a
reputation for the number of children
making daring escapes
Lorraine pompana attended the school
during that time she was taken from her
family on the nearby Sioux Valley Dakota
Nation Reserve at the age of six
what do you remember about arriving at
the school I didn't want to come I was
crying and uh screaming and I was
hanging on to my dad's legs and but they
tore me away
there was so much loneliness I felt like
running away even at that age you know
but where would I go like you know
Brandon was known for kids running away
yes do you remember that happening yes I
recall that because the school had three
three floors some of the girls came out
through the window and they strung
sheets together
Lorraine can't recall what happened to
that particular group of girls
she says students would just vanish from
the school and no one would say what
happened to them
her most Vivid memories though are about
the food they'd be forced to eat each
day
two slices of bread soaked in lard it's
this kind of mush bread and that was it
you know and I remember I couldn't
finish eating so I tried to hide it in
my sock but if they found out you really
got punished for that
group punishments consisting of
strappings and beatings were common
later on in my career I worked in the
prison systems as a parole board member
just the claying of the doors the the
the cell doors the the way the buildings
look and and so on just reminds me of
the residential school system it was a
prison yes
[Music]
at its peak operations the Brandon
residential school grounds covered 960
Acres through the use of ground
penetrating radar technology Catherine
and her team have discovered two
forgotten cemeteries the school's first
cemetery is located along the
Assiniboine River on privately owned
land
56 unmarked graves are suspected to be
there
a second Cemetery was created north of
the school sometime in the 1920s it
contains another suspected 24 Graves and
is located on land owned by the federal
government
Sue Valley also owns a portion of the
land where the main building once stood
possible unmarked Graves have been
discovered in two locations around the
school
thank you everyone for coming and for
all your hard work
Catherine is working with Elders on the
project
Gerald Bell has been involved since the
beginning
some of the attitudes we ran into were
you know they're they're dead you know
we don't know who they are why are you
so concerned
you know it's not your child it's not
your relative but but it is all nations
were all related
so that's a concept I think that that
people outside the native community
don't understand in the group itself
without the elders knowledge and oral
Traditions many of these Graves would
have remained unknown beneath the long
grass
how did these burial sites get erased
It's a combination of long-term neglect
and and no system in place for long-term
care at the first school cemetery near
the Assiniboine River we have multiple
erasures happening over time
in 1921 the federal government leased
the land containing the burial grounds
to the city of Brandon over time the
grave markers were removed and the area
was transformed into a public park
in the late 1960s the local Rotary Club
and Girl Guides placed a plaque and a
fence around the site after a former
student campaigned for its protection
then in 2001 the land was sold to a
private owner by then the property had
become a campground and it changed hands
multiple times before being sold to the
current owners in 2007.
sometime during this period the fence
was removed and with it the most visible
public marker of the graves and the
cemeteries only being rediscovered now
we wanted to visit the burial ground to
see what condition it's in today
so we got in touch with the campground's
owner Mark Kovach
hi is this Mark
yes it is
bubble
Mark if he would show us the cemetery
near the river
no I'm not interested in doing any more
press he denied us access to the site
and declined to speak with us on camera
he told us he didn't know there was a
burial ground there when he purchased
the land in 2007 and that he's been
working with Sioux Valley in the
province to erect defense around the
grave site
but recently that relationship has
broken down due to disagreements over
how to proceed with that work
Sue Valley had planned to conduct field
work in the fall of 2022 to identify
where the fence should go but Mark
denied them entry to the property
all we're asking for
the vanity
Sioux Valley Dakota Nation Chief
Jennifer bone says all levels of
government need to help communities
access and commemorate these sacred
sites
we didn't create these problems right
but now if we want
something done then it's up to us to do
that which I don't think is fair
[Music]
and this will have been where my
grandmother was taken
feels strange to be going somewhere
where she would have come as a young
very very young child
before relocating to England Melanie
bagley's grandmother lived on a reserve
Northeast of Winnipeg and attended
Brandon residential school
on this day Melanie and her brother are
visiting the former School site for the
first time
Melanie was unaware of her indigenous
Heritage until she was in her 20s
since then she's been on a journey to
learn more about her family's ancestry
that I said to my grandmother
what was it like growing up on the
reserve and what was it like going to
residential school
so gentle soft-spoken woman and she just
turned to me she said
we never talk about that
and it was like
okay I don't know what that means but I
must never ever ever ask her again
and she didn't but she remained curious
while researching her grandmother's
school life she stumbled upon an unknown
part of her family history
her grandmother had a younger sister
Lina who also went to the school
when I found that I had like a shock
well I've never heard of her so I spoke
to another cousin and another cousin and
nobody's ever heard of her
and so
who who is she where where did she go
and what has it been like for you
discovering that you have this great
aunt that you you never knew you had
it's been
it's been a roller coaster really it's
been up and down and
it's been difficult when there's an
unclosed chapter it's really hard to
feel okay about things
there's about 24 children that might be
buried in this area
I've gone from sad
and you know about on the verge of tears
actually anger yeah that's how I've gone
but it's not right that people
do that to small children
standing in the cemetery Melanie's
thoughts turn to the fate of her great
aunt Lena
I'm really hoping with the records show
that she aged out you know she became a
grandmother and
lived you know fairy tale Happy Ever
After but my gut feeling is that she
he probably didn't
yeah so we're honoring her today
she's now submitted a request for more
information about Lena to the National
Center For Truth and Reconciliation
Raymond frogner is the head archivist
there
like Catherine Raymond is building a
list of names of children who died or
went missing while attending residential
schools
but he's doing it for the 139 schools
that existed across Canada
he and his team have combed through
about 4 million pages to uncover the
identities of lost children
they are predominantly the
administrative records of the operations
of schools
it does first blush seem to be quite
mundane and not very revealing but as a
sum total the records document a school
system that was designed for the ratio
of of indigenous Societies in Canada
to date the National Memorial register
has grown to include the names of
4120 children
do you expect to add more absolutely I
would say
um we only have maybe a third of the
names that we'll have in our final
report
and as they gain access to more records
the list will continue to grow
just finding students names is an
arduous process
not only because records are incomplete
if they exist at all
but also because of the concerted
efforts to erase children's indigenous
identities
so when children arrived at the schools
they were given western names and often
would be assigned a number as well and
so very frequently in the reports to
Indian Affairs for example the names of
children were included at all they were
just numbers
and part of the problem too is the way
that names were recorded we have
examples of students at residential
schools over many years that had over 15
different forms of their name
I asked Lorraine about this
when you arrived at the school
I imagine they asked for your name how
did that work like did they record your
name I'm not sure because they didn't
get it right
what do you mean my name is deloraine
according to the record I saw okay so
it's not even your name no no and that
happened to many people
and some were forced to take another
name
and then did you get a number I got a
number and I just can't recall right now
it seems to me it could be 45 but I'm
not sure
when the school building was finally
torn down in 2000 Lorraine went to watch
I got this brick from this site when it
was being demolished it means that I
survived the system I survived whatever
happened here on this hill and I'm not
in one of those Graves up there
and why is this work of uncovering the
identities the names of these children
so important I think it's a question of
Human Rights human dignity equality and
respect
um that if we are going to have a
society based on these principles these
human values that has to begin with an
understanding and until we have a full
understanding of what has happened it's
going to be difficult to go forward and
build that society that we are aspire to
live in
Catherine and Sue Valley now embark on a
challenging Next Step
locating the living descendants of the
99 children on their list
there are so many affected communities
with many different cultural backgrounds
and so it's just essential that with the
relatives have direct input on what
happens next
still don't know which Graves coincide
with which children are buried there and
that makes it
exceedingly challenging when families
ask where their children are buried and
we can't tell them
we don't have those answers
for that Graves would need to be exhumed
and tested for DNA
some communities have already begun that
next phase
While others are just beginning their
search for answers
it's going to take a lot of work from a
lot of people
and we're here for the Long Haul
to find all of the missing children
[Music]